[Music]
all right we are live uh what's going on
man how are you
what's going on gentlemen
so we have patrick campbell well the
company was profitwell
yeah but originally it was
it was something else
for first right yeah we called it price
intelligently so we did a little piece
of pricing software morphed into pricing
software and service
a lot of service actually and then
started building this metrics tool and
all that kind of fun stuff and then
recently sold the paddle which is a
payments infrastructure product and the
headline the headline price was 200
million dollars and you bootstrapped the
company and i think in a tweet you said
you owned i don't know if it was you and
your co-founder or company owned but
like you guys owned almost all of it
right
yeah we were bootstrapped so we owned
100 of it um and so we uh yeah but we
were pretty generous i think i tweeted
about the fact that we're pretty
generous about giving out equity so it
wasn't like i had 100
um we had i think the headline number is
we had 13 millionaires we had like 30 35
people made 6ks or more and then i think
there's like 120 people all in people
who had worked at the company previously
in the current employees who got some
sort of consideration out of the deal so
i think
it was true it was over 200
it was over 200 technically like we're
not public i don't know it's so weird
about these numbers it's like what are
you public with what are you not and i
have a board and a boss now so i have to
have to be a little careful not that
careful but a little careful about all
the things i say you do you do seem like
you're cultivating that trillionaire
energy that we like to seize
i gotta say i'm getting the vibe i'm
getting that i'm getting that extreme
satisfaction and relief vibe that comes
when you sell a company well sean ask
him
how tightly wound i am so yeah that's
interesting ask him where he just moved
to go ahead tell them
where did you just move to
uh i moved to puerto rico for all the
obvious reasons just put it out there
just to be very clear uh very obvious
reasons why i moved here and it's 80 and
i'm not a huge fan of the heat but uh i
am like basically recording with a 6k
camera right now and that's that's that
trillionaire energy where it's like
where do you put the money i don't like
cars so i got a really cool like dope
set up basically i mean that bookshelf
needs a little upgrade too if i must be
honest here i feel like this was
literally like ikea i don't have
anything behind me like let's throw some
books up and kind of go from there so
we'll we'll get there we'll get there so
what what exactly did you guys i i we
used you i believe but i think we got i
think we used you for free and i was
like how did these guys make money what
exactly did did you guys do
yeah so the the headline kind of
positioning is we we basically exist to
run and grow subscription businesses
automatically and the automatically
thing was the thing that like really
worked well for us
um and what i mean by that is like in
the perfect vision world you should be
able to plug in profit well to any
subscription business so into stripe
charge be zora whatever you're using for
your billing and then automatically like
you get all of your metrics for free
which is probably what you're
referencing and then um we reduce your
churn your cancellations automatically
optimize your pricing automatically and
now with the whole paddle deal we like
take care of your taxes automatically
chargebacks all that kind of fun stuff
and so yeah i think the the the big
thing for us was
when we were this pricing service um we
wanted to get to something that was more
pure software
and we were helping a company with their
pricing that was about to ipo and we
actually discovered they were
calculating mrr and churn completely
wrong which was really fascinating um
and so we kind of put those two insights
together and then started producing this
metrics product so you get all of your
financial reporting if you're a
subscription or sas company
and then there were like 30 competitors
and it was like all overnight like the
space where we thought we were going to
be billionaires for like metrics all of
a sudden it was like oh my god like
everyone and their mother is building a
stripe integration and so um we did some
homework we did some research all that
kind of fun stuff and basically
discovered that like either this is a
terrible business and we should stop
doing it because no one is really great
at monetizing metrics or the free route
which is what we did and um i think
that's probably when we should have
raised money like in in hindsight
but long story short that's what grew
and we had at the end well it's still
going but we had 30 000 companies using
profitwell um basically when we sold and
that number is just kind of going up
every single day which is great
and when you you reached out to us and
you were like hey i think you do you
listen to the pod is that kind of why
you reached out of course yeah
absolutely i'm glad to hang out with the
12 year olds from a recent episode i
learned yeah you said something which
kind of tipped me off you were like i
grew up in wisconsin doing hood rat
hat tip to sam i was like oh okay he
knows jokes he knows about sometimes you
just want to do hood ratchet
of course that's why we're getting a
ranch built in utah right now
everything's gonna be great like that's
that's that's the hood wrap world there
are are you really you're building a
ranch in utah
yeah that's the goal so i grew up in
wisconsin right so i grew up like
literally milking cows as a kid and like
you know kind of having the let's say
the sampar lifestyle like my dad has no
idea what i do
he's like just confused he thinks i'm
being a tax evader moving to puerto rico
like all that kind of fun
blue collar sam he's like he was just
more rich
yeah yeah
what'd you say sean that's funny yeah
yeah he's like you're just more rich
it looks like it that's what it
i do what i can s think the difference
is that sam's living a little like i'm
like all in like just still like nose to
the grindstone but yeah i grew up in
wisconsin and then after school i moved
to dc i worked in us intelligence and
then worked in tech in boston and that's
kind of when i got into the to the
business space basically
but what i was gonna say is you reached
out intelligently because we get a bunch
of people who are like hey would love to
come on and tell my story it's like yeah
i'm sure you would who wouldn't want to
come on and tell their story like
i also like to get you know free fame
but the the thing you did was you sent
us like i don't know six or seven bullet
points you're like
uh here's you know here's some stuff i
can talk about and then you sent us i
would say like five or six really
interesting things so i kind of want to
hop around on those
um
sam did you have a favorite one that you
liked from these
uh okay well let's so do you have it in
front of you it's hidden industries i
got in front of it so okay so yeah
that's the juicy
that's the juicy one so basically you
said i think we have the largest
subscription financial database in the
world right like you you guys have 100
20 30 billion dollars of annual
recurring revenue flowing through your
system which is just a bunch of
data that will tell you i bet you
there's some things that are like huh no
way they make that much right there's
like some surprising niches that that
make a lot of money and then there's
maybe some trends or benchmarks so take
it where you want it but i think that's
one that's going to be super interesting
for
i know i want to know i don't know the
answer so i know people listening will
too yeah totally so there's there's
there's a couple things so one like just
to give an example like um
we we would always like so we study the
data in aggregate that's what helps like
train our algorithms for like churn
reduction and all that kind of fun stuff
but then the other really interesting
thing is like we publish a lot of
content on this so a lot of sas
companies it's like oh what should our
churn be what should this look like so
we publish a lot of that the other thing
that got really interesting was we would
basically be kind of like a hidden like
helper for deal flow for a lot of vcs
and we would never like reveal someone's
like particular numbers of course not
but like what was really fascinating is
when kind of the the jungle scout amazon
you know kind of play was happening like
we would all of a sudden have like all
of these apps just break our qa scripts
because every time like someone was
growing too fast we would go oh
something must be broken with the
metrics right right so that's a little
bit of context um there's like three or
four really fascinating industries
especially going into a recession that i
think are really good for like people
who want to fast move into them
one
one of these industries that's kind of
crazy to talk about quilting and crafts
quilting and crafts subscription
companies are like growing insane um
what's fascinating is the quilting space
if the if you didn't know quilting is um
it's about a four and a half billion
dollar per year industry um the average
quilter spends about eight to nine
thousand dollars per year on like
quilting supplies um most of that comes
not just online but it comes through
quilt shops so there's a really
interesting local play that we've seen
some of these companies um use and some
of the more popular apps quilting just
means like making a blanket that has
like designs on it right
uh for the most part um now as a mom a
midwest mom who does hardcore quilting
like there's a lot of other stuff like
our house we didn't have pictures up we
had quilts that were hung right of like
different designs and all kinds of stuff
but yeah every major milestone in my
life i got a quilt like i have six
quilts in puerto rico that are useless
to me just given how like warm it is
here
there's there's paint i see went to
someone else's house they had a painting
on the wall it's like no no you don't
need that just put a blanket on the wall
yeah yeah it's great sound deadening
it's really good sound ending but yeah
it's really interesting because like
that market has gone wild like even like
knitting like crafts that type of stuff
and what's really interesting about it
is like especially in the subscription
space there's a lot of these built-in
type projects that these companies have
started taking advantage of so there's
this thing called block of the month
club that has been around since quilters
have existed
you create a block of a quilt every
single you know month basically and it's
like a community type thing um so
there's something there
quilt retreats are a huge thing like
quilt retreats like i didn't know about
that like all of these mostly like
middle aged or older women coming
together like hanging out and staying up
all night talking and like you know
quilting so that's one space the craft
space knitting all that kind of stuff is
really interesting
another one that's interesting is uh
basically old people uh but before you
move on before sam yeah do you know
stuff about quilting i feel like you
know we have knowledge about this stuff
no i i don't but i'm looking at i just
googled block of the month club so that
that's like a that's like a genre of
clubs that's not like the name of a of a
club right and i just i'm just looking
at yeah or i don't know a style and i'm
looking up what what these are what
these are and i'm looking at the
businesses
it wouldn't shock me if some of these
are doing nine figures so 100 million
dollars plus in subscription revenue
based off there's some other traffic
like there's craftsy there's annie's
kit clubs.com do you know anything about
these
yeah yeah so there's there's there are
definitely nine figure companies in the
space i'll put it that way and then nine
figures a year so 100 million plus in
subscription revenue for sell and they
basically like i don't know what
differentiates all them i'm just
clicking on the ads but they just sell
like they send you a block you know what
a block is sean like just one square
patch of the quilt
a square patch and during the holidays
this is making my dreams come true right
now just this whole like learning you
guys right now people think that i i am
midwestern i grew up in like an urban
environment so i grew up in like the
city so we didn't we weren't exactly
quilting but we basically what they do
is they they send you a patch like a
like a block like a six inch by six inch
block and it looks like it's like got
like
pumpkins and a snowman on it and that's
like the holiday version of what do you
do with that you stitch that into the
other blocks that you've been getting
yeah
so basically here's here's how quilt
gets made i can't believe i'm about to
explain this so a quilt gets made by
these blocks now sometimes it's just
designs sometimes it's got stuff on it
like snowmen and stuff like that so you
create these blocks you build a top so
let's say you want like a king-sized bed
it's just the top so it's just one layer
of fabric
what you do is you take it to a quilt
shop
and then you go to the quilt shop and
that quilt shop is going to charge you
per inch to put a back and then a
batting which is like the stuff that
makes it kind of a blanket and then they
like put a design in there as they like
put those layers together and then you
have a quilt um right and then some
hardcore moms like my mom has her own
basically quilting machine it's like an
eight-foot machine to basically make all
of these quilts out so yeah it's and
this is the thing your mom's a bad 99 of
them are on like facebook they're all
like they're really targetable which is
really fascinating and
like the youtube content that's come out
of like the quilt community is pretty
wild as well
and um yeah there's there's this one in
missouri i can't remember exactly but it
was like this town that was like
basically you know on its last legs this
woman her you know basically her son
started doing youtube videos where she
would just explain how to do quilting
stuff it's created it basically
revitalized the town like because
everyone comes on buses to come visit
the town and go to the quilt shop and
all that kind of fun stuff and um the
quilt shows quilt and craft shows are
pretty fascinating
this is all my childhood coming out
because i got dragged to use bookstores
and quilt shops basically
and the quilt shows are wild like
they'll just be famous quilters on stage
with a camera like doing quilt stuff
like basically which is just kind of a
fascinating world and it's a lot of
money in it that's like kind of like old
school meaning like there's a couple of
really big players that kind of sell
everything
and there's all these new school folks
coming in and kind of lopping off
different segments
that i would look at
uh so the one i was describing
uh
these moms while you're looking at that
up these moms these quilters are not
using instagram a lot it looks like i'm
like looking up quilting on instagram
and facebook groups real heavy
there's not a ton of pages on instagram
that are doing quilting but it's like an
opportunity by the way uh to like build
big quilting pages on instagram they are
facebook groups they're the facebook
group i've seen everyone just
researching while i'm here i'm looking
at tons of highly engaged quilting
facebook groups
well it's also interesting like you'll
even in boston like there'll be these
little like meetups so the younger
community they're kind of going through
um knitting into like quilting because
it's like oh you get to build something
the designs are a lot more modern all
that kind of fun stuff but
yeah it's an interesting interesting
world a missouri star quilt company is
the one that i was referencing the
youtube kind of kind of world how big is
that
uh i don't know their revenue
individually i don't think they have a
subscription sean have you heard of
hallmark you know hallmark cards
of course
so neighbor used to own like 50 hallmark
stores really i was like how's these how
are these people so rich and they're
like oh now they own like 100 hallmarks
so hallmark is an interesting company
related to this and i'm everything i'm
saying is is off the top of my off
memory so i may be wrong but
they hallmark is a privately owned
business it's owned by a family and i
think it's one of the largest privately
owned companies in the world in america
and they do five billion dollars a year
in revenue and i think that they make
money in two ways they uh have these
stores that are franchises and they just
sell cards so hallmark just sells cards
and then the other thing that's kind of
weird is they owned hallmark media which
is a hallmark
tv station channel yeah yeah where they
make like it's a joke it's like a genre
hallmark movies which is like sappy
movies that moms like
but i wouldn't be surprised if they own
like if if they're just like uh you know
behind the scenes in the quilting game
just calling the shots you know what i
mean
they're deep in the underground quilt
game yeah
[Laughter]
some of the big originals they're huge
this this hobby i think has legs for a
couple reasons one is
um
it has a bunch of factors that
individually are
strong characters of like you know
potentially good businesses but when you
stack them it becomes even more valuable
so it's like this is a stacking of
trends so you have the trend of diy and
crafts at home right then you have the
trend of oddly satisfying which is
you've seen these videos of people
cutting sand or like asmr
stuff like this which is like there's a
therapeutic benefit to doing these
things tac like these repetitive tedious
clean straight lines you know stuff with
your hands that you can do that has like
a tactile feel to it then you add on
community and it's like oh yeah people
get together and they do this together
okay so now this is an excuse it's like
you know guys getting together to play
poker or something like that it's like
yeah yeah we don't all really you know
we're not trying to be the best poker
player but it's just an excuse to sit
around and and so you start
stacking these on top of each other then
it's like nostalgia because people are
making quilts out of like their kids
clothes and stuff like that because you
know they don't want you what else yeah
what do i do with these old stuff and
then all it becomes this like this like
memory in this heirloom and i'm like you
know i have a blanket that my grandma
made before she passed away and it's
like that means something to our family
because she made it right it's like a
memory of her so you stack all these
things on top of each other and now you
have this like you know sort of like
this uh
you know long island iced tea of a
business where you stacked all these
different you know things into one
cocktail and it's it's just a strong you
know son of a additionally i think
uh maybe you could kind of tell me if
this is true or not but from my
experience
most people in silicon valley and young
people they're like we're going to make
this app or this widget for like
millennials or gen z
in reality every business that i know of
personally that or
the majority of my friends who own
businesses that sell stuff to women in
middle america between the ages of 30
and 60
hands down
has the highest loyalty and engagement
and lowest amount of churn is that
accurate
other than businesses i'm a group of
consumers
yeah so normally if you're selling to
normally older audiences from a consumer
perspective retain at a higher rate
um mainly because of the implications
that you're already alluding to um it's
they're less finicky like they're harder
to convert sometimes because of that
loyalty but once they're in they've like
made a decision and then they're they're
sticking it out for quite some time um
and this is kind of like as a lesson
like i can tell you
anytime there is a more premium product
or a more niche audience
you just have better churn like every
single time so like butcher box started
with the you know whole kind of paleo
crowd a very niche it was very premium
in terms of price point worked out
really well whoops started very high
they were like we're athletes and then
all these people who were like i want to
be an athlete too and they're charging
30 bucks a month right um that's always
what i recommend is if you're starting
something especially if you're
bootstrapping um start high and then
come down it's a lot easier um than it
is to like start really cheap and then
go back up unless you're running a
freemium model which is a very different
model to run sean have you ever been
doing have you been doing applebee's
lately
oh hell yeah chili's and applebee's baby
have you really been doing applebees
yes i have
that's hilarious um so do you know how
their whole shtick is like even though
it's a chain it like they they put like
the neighborhood baseball team on the
wall which who knows if it's they're
actually from that neighborhood like you
know whenever you go there they make it
feel like that well
i had a friend that worked on the
advertising
part of of applebee's and one time we
had to go there and like order
everything on the menu and drink and eat
it all it was horrible but i was like
tony this food is like quite bad like
this is horrible i don't like i don't i
don't think you're gonna be able to be
able to make this cool like you know
you're telling me like a it was like a
nuclear green
like limeade
like i was like dude this is horrible i
don't want to drink this this is
awful or like one time why does the
cheese taste like beans and the beans
taste like cheese let's go yeah well
they they sent over something i'm like i
don't know what this is and so we dipped
it in there and it was icing uh like it
was like a side of icing and i was like
dude this is horrible why do people like
this he's like well it's mostly middle
america and they call i believe that
they called their ideal customer a jim
bob which is someone who is in their 50s
60s and 70s and has a little bit of
money but wants to continue going there
because it feels like it's the last like
hoorah for the neighborhood and they're
supporting their neighborhood and
they're willing to put up with the
crappy food because it somehow feels
like their way of life is under attack
and this is like the last
like thing that represents their
neighborhood even though it's some huge
national yeah the world is changing so
much and this is all this is the one
staple that like you walk in and it
feels exactly the same as it did when
you were 14
right
what yeah are we gonna say i literally
wrote this last night so i'm reading a
slack message last night 12 35 a.m so
right after midnight i just slacked this
to myself
i i wrote if you're selling a cool thing
to a cool person you're playing the game
wrong that is hard mode and this is all
of you know you meet most people in d2c
most people in silicon valley it's like
they're they are in their 20s they're
cool and new in the world and they're
selling to cool and new people in la and
new york and san francisco and they're
like yeah of course like you know i'm
gonna create this new cool thing and i'm
gonna sell it to new cool people
and what you wanna do is you wanna sell
simple things to simple people
and so um and i had a buddy tell me this
with um
a project i was working on he goes he
goes okay so what's your main like sales
channel i was like oh facebook ads he
goes
okay so that means your customer at
scale is an overweight overworked mom in
texas
and he's like so i look at your website
and i don't see anything that like
appeals to her uh like it doesn't have
to look like her at least to look like
how she wants to look
and um and it basically was like you
know if you can't sell
to an overweight overworked mom in texas
like you can't scale and i was like what
the hell like okay okay you don't even
know any overweight overworked moms in
texas do you i used to live in houston
that turned out to be a valuable it's
just like you were saying like you know
my mom used to drag me probably kicking
and screaming to these quilting shows
and now that you're an entrepreneur
you're like ooh quilting niche tell me
more right like it's like we flip you
know the thing we used to resist now we
we you know want to want to go go for it
and so it's the same thing like growing
up in texas that's like man i just
thought everything cool was in new york
and san francisco and la and i just
wanted to go there and now that i'm here
i'm like dude i don't want to sell to
these like fickle millennials who are
like you know
you know trying to do like berry detoxes
like i want to sell you know something
to a mom in texas because if i can do
that that's a license to print money and
like if you go look at you know the
best-selling car
the last i don't know 30 years is the
ford f-150 it's a you know it's a pickup
truck that sells for for 36 thousand
dollars you go around san francisco you
won't see one
right
you know you would think the
best-selling car in america is the tesla
model x you know and it's like
that's just not the case uh because
you're in you're in a bubble
and so you know and i think the jim bob
you know overweight mom in texas the you
know the other one is you know the
enterprise sales one is like you know
you're selling to bob the mid-level
manager or the senior manager who's you
know got a little bit of a belly and
he's losing his hair like that's who
you're selling to and you gotta like can
you nail that sale because if you can
you could build a very very big business
and i mean that like the most loving way
possible which is basically just saying
to most entrepreneurs and most kind of
young people like get out of your bubble
well you end up not chasing fads
like there's a lot of fads like business
builds on built on fads right and and
those are great businesses right like we
hear about them all the time the guy who
what was it the um
the teeth like i can't remember like the
the hillbilly teeth you remember this at
gas stations like apparently like 20
million like business right like the
snuggie huge fad you know hundreds of
millions of dollars i believe in revenue
but
like something like quilting has been
around forever it's not sexy right but
the targeting gets really interesting
and like some of the other things right
like you guys talk about this a lot
where it's like services business you
know lawn care hvac all these other
things end up being like stuff that
sticks around for a long time and you
know through the businesses that you
don't really hear of and there's a lot
of opportunity in terms of roll up or
like flipping the model that you know
was basically being used by the folks
that are the incumbents so what are some
of these other if you're if you're going
to innovate innovate on just one thing
so it's like oh quilting people love but
there's not a lot of instagram theme
pages and communities on instagram okay
that's like
it's just like i can do one new thing on
top of nine old time you know uh nine
things that are still gonna be the same
and that's like a new thing right sam
did the news
but he did it through email instead of
through you know printed papers right
and so like one new thing and then he
didn't need to change everything else
everything else could stay the same
because the human needs stayed the same
oh yeah sorry we went a
long ass time on quilting but talking
about quilting baby that's great yeah
what else do you got what are some other
kind of niches three other spaces have
to go deeper uh trades roll-ups plumbing
companies hvac companies electrician
companies there's a lot of that stuff
happening
it's not like machine shops or those
types of things where it's just like
hard to innovate it's like skilled
enough that there's a niche and there's
like a moat but it's not skilled enough
that you can't roll it up a lot of these
guys and gals are looking for basically
a way to retire and it's kind of like
accountant you know shops like they
don't get more than one x max right in
terms of their business
um basically things to sell to kids of
old people that's the best way to look
what is that what does that mean i don't
know i saw you wrote that products that
prey on baby boomer kid guilt
yeah yeah so a really good example um
it's not a huge company because it's a
one-man shop out of boston is nanograms
it's basically a um i don't know if you
email or you post it on instagram and
then it automatically sends a postcard
to your nana or to you know whomever you
want to send it to
um so there's some really interesting
things that are happening there where
like you have high disposable income in
a certain group low amount of time that
wants to be spent necessarily with like
you know
their parents or their grandparents
depending on you know the the
personality
um and as basically the trend that's
happening is there's a huge portion of
population that are aging so you're
seeing like the multiples on things like
um old folks homes or hospice care
actually increasing pretty substantially
which is kind of crazy and then there's
there's got to be more technology plays
i don't have like a giant technology
play there i just have seen like a
number of people like start to build on
that particular trend
um and then the last one which i think
is really interesting is death
that sounded terrible that i found death
interesting no i'm not that that's scary
but um
there are four
or maybe five companies that basically
own everything in the literal last mile
of your life coffins um uh the the
funeral service homes everything that's
being sold in the funeral service homes
even like how the memories and kind of
like that last part looks um there are
some businesses that have tried but
because of like the five people kind of
owning everything and multi-billion
dollar companies what's the biggest
essentially happened
i don't have the names in front of me i
know someone tried five years ago
um a guy named dave balter in boston
basically tried to start a like memory
company where basically you would
load up memories essentially and then
all of a sudden you would get that
information back
via alexa so you could be like oh alexa
would tell me about my grandpa or
something like that and what happened
like six years ago or something with him
um in an adventure but um he was the one
telling me that like basically he would
go visit you know these companies like
hey maybe i could sell to these
companies and they were all like
buttoned up suits you know all that kind
of fun stuff and so that's a space that
i think given the aging population
there's probably something there that
makes sense as well
gotcha okay
let's switch gears real quick you had
said something else which was um
let's do some quick hits okay so let's
try to do these
uh give me the kind of the quick quick
jab on these you said
i used nsa learnings to do competitive
intelligence what the hell are you
talking about yeah yeah yeah so i my
first job out of school i worked at nsa
uh so i was an intel analyst best way to
put it i was like jack ryan's desk job
so none of the cool stuff i did have
weapons and defensive driving training
which is kind of cool the defensive
driving training is like so much more
useful than the weapons training in my
real life um but what's really
interesting about it is
like
it's basically was the best career start
in like first principles thinking and
like thinking about like a target
um and so i had a competitive intel
program basically at profitwell it was
just me running it where um i had every
quarter i had stats and it's kind of
like what you guys have talked about
before but like a little bit deeper so
what i did is i had shadow lists of like
our each competitor even our partners
like customers and i would send like
shadow nps surveys um you know product
research surveys these types of things
and the thing that people miss on
competitive intel is like it has to be
done over time um and this is something
that like they teach you when you're
going after a target on the inside which
is like i need to understand not just a
point i need to understand like multiple
points in order to kind of create a
profile basically and how did you get
this how did you get that mps stuff
no he said he sent a fake nps i straight
up sent surveys to their customer sent
surveys to their so walk me through that
how do you get through all your research
methodologies this is crazy fascinating
yeah yeah so um there's two there's two
main sources of information there's
moles and then mass data moles are like
qualitative like almost like customer
development product conversations these
are former employees these are um you
know customers i know that are friendly
to me they're not going to switch
because of whatever but i can like talk
to them okay well let's pause that
former employees you go you find okay
this person used to work here
what what happens what is the what is
the guy i do this all the time present
this way yeah me and sam talked about
this on the pod once but totally so i
like you meet him at a conference uh oh
it looked like on twitter that didn't
end well they weren't like after four
long wonderful years at so and so i've
now moved on but it was like i'm now
over here right they took out the
competitor name that's someone i want to
like
like a better phrase target and have a
conversation with and be like hey man
how's everything going right like that
type of a thing um and again you're not
going to get a vast amount of
information but again it's about
collecting different points right and
then i've talked to an investor and then
i've talked to an investor who's
thinking of investing in the company and
then i've talked to like some customers
who are officially churning from the
product and all of a sudden i can start
putting this together but
that the more fascinating stuff and
that's color right like that's color
that kind of guides your analysis
because you as an analyst
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to predict what's going to happen
or based on some sort of stimulus what
they're going to do right so if all of a
sudden something comes in or there's a
feature that's launched or some sort of
messaging or marketing thing that
happens what are they going to do and
that's going to help you respond to
whatever they're going to do right and
prepare for it right so that was really
interesting because you almost get like
feel from those types of people like oh
it turns out like there's an exodus a
lot of people are leaving that's great
let's step on the gas here but the real
kind of secret sauce is what you know
sam started asking about which was
there are many lists of customers that
you can find um if they have some sort
of a snippet obviously built with clear
bit all those types of things right
that's one
everyone likes to talk about their
customers right so they have case
studies that's two everyone likes to put
the logos on their website that's three
right and so you're looking at social
you're looking at built with you're
looking at all these logos and then i'm
like well who's the main customer right
i can go find all those email addresses
right and you're not looking for like oh
my god i have ten thousand people
because most of these people have ten
thousand customers right but we're
looking for is enough but then i'm gonna
start sending on in every three month
basis a survey or every other month i'm
going to send an nps survey and then i'm
going to send so what domain did you
send the survey from like yeah like your
name plus feedback feedback.com or
something or what
there's a couple i don't want to go too
deep but like like probably like
meditation's already fried on this so
like um
let's say you're let let's say you're
trying to uh let's say you're creating a
hubspot competitor and you want to get
hubspot mps information you send an
email that it's like um
uh
hubspacefeedback.com or like get hubspot
feedback.com or something like that
i wouldn't go that far because if
someone finds that out like it looks
real bad right um but what i would and
i'm sure people are gonna think
everything i'm saying is really bad but
like whatever right and so what i would
do is i'll do more like marketing
softwareresearch.com or something to
that effect
and then the way that i position it is
hey so and so you've been identified as
a user of hubspot i would love 30
seconds of your time to understand what
you love and what you don't love right
and the 30 seconds there 30 to 60
seconds there is really important we've
sent our pricing software's fed through
surveys we've sent like probably 10
million surveys at this point
if you're not compensating someone on an
individual basis the raffle thing
doesn't work it's i mean it will work
with some people but most people doesn't
work but if you're not compensating you
have 30 to 60 seconds so i'll send a
survey that max five questions right
nps standard question here's five
features what's the most appreciated
most preferred feature of that list same
list what's the least preferred right so
three questions maybe i'll throw in uh
anything else you want to tell us about
hubspot right and then all of a sudden i
have like a picture and then i'm gonna
send oh it's interesting we're thinking
about building this thing they're
thinking about building that thing like
let's do something next next quarter or
next month but the same survey can be
sent multiple different times but the
important thing here is you're building
a timeline right because now all of a
sudden i can see these trends and what
was really interesting and the thing
that i told you guys about was not only
so first you should never show this
information to your product team it is
the worst information like we've seen
like competitive based product teams are
really bad like it just doesn't work um
but i have data and i'm happy to share
it that competitive based marketing
teams like teams that it's correlative
of course it's not causal but those
folks who have competitive programs
typically have much better retention and
lower cac so because they just
understand what are you talking about
what basically he's saying what in
planning is what he's saying is
you learn this stuff if you go tell the
product team hey here's here's what they
said they want or here's what you should
build them up they screws them up they
don't they don't build the right stuff
but if you go you should be part of the
team and you say here's what's here's
what pain points were most important to
them or here's what benefits were most
important to them or here's what here's
how they rank these guys versus us
the marketing teams
if you have that competitive intel as
part of your process a marketing team
will perform better than a marketing
team without that perfect example real
world example we start hearing this is
the early days of the metrics product we
realize getting accuracy for metrics is
actually incredibly difficult because
it's not like marketing metrics that can
be like five percent off like financial
metrics if you tell me i have this much
money that's supposed to be in my bank
account i'm making decisions based off
that it has to be 99.9 if not 100 right
so we start feeling this just as a
product team
all of a sudden we start hearing from
some of my like my my moles if you will
and they don't know that they were these
people just to be clear it's not like i
turned them and they're like you know
there's drops and everything like that
but also i start hearing like ah yeah
we're using up the accuracy sucks right
so all of a sudden we start hearing this
totality of information all of a sudden
that is our core marketing strategy
every single time comparison pages we
didn't do that many of them but every
single comparison page is the number one
thing
all of our ads like competitive ads
that's what they were and then over time
all of a sudden that became their home
pages right because they're reacting to
us rather than us reacting to them
because we found the snippet that makes
the most sense
and the the most like
aggressive thing um if this doesn't
sound aggressive enough is so i have all
this data i have all this information
i've collected it i've synthesized it
i know by the way do you keep that like
a spreadsheet or like a notion and
you're making and you're writing like
narrative formats
it depends on how i'm using it right so
the data is just tracking over time
right so i've i can send you like some
slides or something like that so i have
some slides that like i put together for
when we were going to go raise money for
the first time as well because it's just
really good data in general
one thing i have is is basically
spreadsheets that has a lot of this
information especially the qualitative
and then the other thing that i build
off of this are red team docs i don't
know if you guys know what those are but
basically like
every thought i've had or every thought
that i learned from this data because
this data like customer data and market
data is probably 10x more important but
this is like some interesting data
that's easy to talk about in a podcast
um but red team docs is when i look at
all this data it's like what are the
things that kill us every single thought
that i've had that could like kill us or
hurt us goes into a dock some of those
docs get built out oh
someone accuses me of x someone says
this on twitter and then it basically at
minimum has here are the steps that
we're going to take so that when that
thing happens all of a sudden we have a
head start on the little critical piece
of the thinking um
but to make a long story short the the
thing that i reference with you guys is
i would have like these are all funded
competitors
so they would try to go raise money i
would have their um the people they were
trying to raise money from come to me
like not tell me that they were trying
to raise money but it's obvious because
they invest in the space it's not the
associate it's like the partner coming
like all that kind of stuff some of them
would straight up tell me like hey we're
thinking of investing and so and so what
do you think but what i would do then is
i would show them these slides and i
would just basically be like here's all
the information on us and and the person
that you're thinking of investing in i
wouldn't say that unless they were
upfront about it and what it i i know
for one we we killed one of the rounds
that someone was trying to raise like i
can tell you that definitively um
because one like
okay i'm gonna invest in someone going
against this psycho who like has all
this information right like that's
pretty scary thing and then two
like all of our numbers are better
because i you know we just ended up you
know doing really well at certain a
certain number of things right and so um
that that i think is again it's a
program that i think that you should
have at least at a bare minimum um from
a marketing and go to market perspective
if you have a market that becomes really
competitive if you're in like the blue
ocean as they say like it's probably a
waste of time um but it's just something
where our ocean got red real quick um
i think the look on your face tell me
what you're thinking right now i think
i'm very good at research and i'm very
good at doing what i do which is like
doing the exact same thing of finding
moles getting intel reverse engineering
you have said
i think i'm a nine out of ten you have
said some some things to me that i
realize that there's another couple
levels that i can go to improve it's
pretty magical uh the that's pretty
amazing
yeah well then keep in mind
like i have all this market data right
so that was interesting too because all
of a sudden i can understand like so for
example covet hit
again i can't look at anyone's accounts
and we're very very um very very like
strict about that but i can see oh this
sector that has 50 plus accounts which
is our terms this sector's tanking this
sector's taking off i can change my
marketing almost instantly right and
when you have some competitive intel
especially on segments like i knew the
segments that our competitors were going
after and i knew the segments we were
going after um it just helps feed the
wheel and when you're feeding the wheel
and you're getting that phd in your
business which i think is really
important if you're if you're going all
in like all of a sudden it's like
now a lot of the decisions like we don't
have to think about because it's like we
know what's happening we know what
string is being pulled let's react to it
let's respond to it and kind of go from
there
how much of your time is spent on that r
sorry
well now it's a system best way possible
it's a system now so it's a system so i
don't spend that much time i just get
the collect right and it's just
documentation right so for example i
have names like i know i have i have six
names that i can tell you of users of a
competitor of ours i see them pretty
regularly especially since events are
back i'm friends with a couple of them
right and i'm not like
i i'm not hiding the fact like hey how's
it going with competitor a right like
i'm not hiding it right like and that
and that's the thing that like there's a
point here where i think you're you're
kind of being an like and and
you're you know being like conniving and
then there's a point where you're just
like being smart and collecting data and
i try to stay like obviously on that
part of the divide if that makes sense
did you ever think about turning
would you ever turn that into a business
yes yeah i think you could create a
really good business around collecting
nps data honestly g2 crowd reviews
that's where there's a ton of like data
like i would love someone should create
this because it would just do my job
which is great um quarterly report kind
of like for this is the thing forrester
reports i think there's also like a
market to like blow that whole business
up give me like quarterly reports
instead of these reports where you
called 100 people a quarterly report on
the same company or on the same industry
that has
here the reviews the new reviews
positive of a competitor hear the bad
reviews negative of a competitor um
here's mps data all that kind of fun
stuff and you know again you have to be
careful on how much you use this
information like you're using it to
build like a profile you're not using it
to like immediately react to and that's
a mistake a lot of people make shauna
and i had we brainstormed this a lot and
we were talking about how we both use
glass door reviews because even though
like glass doors typically like either
fake or incredibly happy employees or
like disgruntled employees there's not
really a middle but like you could still
get a lot of interesting information
from there and you get instrument
information from like linkedin like
they'll say like you know i manage a
pipeline of a 10 million dollar a year
business and like oh okay thanks for
telling me and like we would like we we
we brainstorm this idea of this business
where we i think we call it like i spy
or something or like it involved like
spying on like many people in a in a
particular industry and just sending you
an email because you can use like
facebook ads manager and be like oh wow
these guys just made a switch they are
now targeting older women as opposed to
younger women
and we called it like spy something and
it's kind of funny you worked for the
nsa you you you you know you are the spy
that we were talking about so like it is
kind of interesting i do think actually
a business could be built doing this
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
i think the problem is is that
so i've been talking about customer
development customer research because
you should do all of this for your
customers that's what you first start
with rather than your competitors like
better stuff sounds sexier right
but i think that like i used to talk
when i give talks at conferences or like
events all about customer development
15 of people like care and then even
when you give them like everyone cares
everyone tweets the tweet oh yeah you
should talk to your customers right 15
people actually do the work and then
when you actually take care of the work
for them and just give them the data and
this is the one risk of this type of a
business i'm sure there's a big business
in it but then they like don't know what
to do with it right and so all of a
sudden it's like okay you're kind of
giving people information which that's
probably fine because it's a vitamin
then like they don't they they like that
they have it right but then actually
implementing on stuff like they probably
don't do it and that means like i don't
know if you if you get a 36 month
customer like i'll take it right like
they don't need to be 60 months
necessarily for for you to build a big
business
right
you're doing one other thing that i find
fascinating
uh actually actually well there's two
you said you're but i'll start with the
less fascinating one you said you're
buying a ton of debt for pennies on
the dollar and gonna forgive it so
what's actually going on there
everyone wants to be mr beast on a long
enough timeline everyone wants to be mr
beast that's what it feels like theory i
like it no so like here's the thing i
i'm probably going to reinvest
everything that i got into this into
like another business did you say how
much how much did you make from the sale
trying i gotta work with a lot of people
uh so i'm trying not to to be super over
or under nine figures
uh
i'm not going to say
what i got let's just put it that way
but um
i was i asked you if it was over or
under 100 million dollars and it took
you a minute to think about it so what
i'm going to assume
it's that number give or take 30 percent
uh
give or take 30 yeah let's just let's
but like again part of its stock it's
not all cash like there's a lot of
different factors here that we i don't
want to get into but i am i'm going to
i'm fine right now
like i'm going to do fine that if that
makes sense so um but i want to reinvest
it because like again i'm i'm not a car
guy i'm not like and again i've had it
for like two months i went from like
this is a fun fact
i did the whole dave ramsey don't have
any debt pay off the house as soon as
possible thing so in january i had
twenty thousand dollars in my bank
account in a paid off house like that
was it and then this happened so um i
haven't adjusted to it is what i'm
trying to say so like this might change
in like six months but i i want to like
you know i want to go all out and go all
out not in a way of like
you know like fancy cars and stuff like
that but like in stuff that's really
interesting and gets me on the quickest
path to learning and one of the reasons
for the debt thing um and also the i
don't know if you're gonna bring up the
other one but like the debt thing was
this mark the debt market's just crazy
like it's insane right it's it's insane
how much debt there is how that debt is
purchased i don't understand it
and this is one of the ways that i can
like really understand it and also do
some good in the world where it's like i
can buy a bunch of debt for pennies on
the dollar i can understand how that
system works how debt collectors work
how the debt collector sell to another
debt collector um and then also like
obviously forgiveness so make it simple
what what debt have you bought what how
are you buying debt what bet are you
buying are you buying it what are you
doing with it
yeah yeah i'm i have not actually
purchased the debt yet right i am
basically exploring right now i just put
some feelers out because that's the
other thing the debt market who did you
reach out to to see if you can acquire
something
see that's the interesting part that's
about to was about to bring up
it's so shadowy
that like there's not like a website
that's like we buy all the debt and then
sell the debt and all that kind of stuff
there's nothing so i have a buddy um i
think he's i don't know if he's cool
with me saying his name but he used to
he runs a really cool subscription
conference now but he used to do this
and i was asking him he was on like the
the board of one of these debt agent
like associations like a business
association and i was like hey man isn't
it scammy and he's explaining to me that
like in that market there's like 20 of
the market that's like very bad like
those are the ones you hear all the
stories about threatening people the
other part of the market like he was in
this he was like he would just call
people and be like hey like what can you
do right because he bought it for
pennies on the dollar so he's like give
me 30 percent great like he made money
they get it done all that this is like
someone who studied that market this is
like someone who owes two thousand
dollars because they got an x-ray or
took an ambulance or um yeah i don't
know whatever else you have credit card
debt for right yeah and the other thing
is the reason the reason this is
interesting and this is like to kind of
speak a little bit more like how i'm
thinking is like i don't want to build a
quilt company although it would be
fascinating don't get me wrong like i
the stuff polymer lucky's doing in
defense i'm i'm all about it the stuff
that like uh aaron swartz did uh before
his passing like in terms of opening up
uh databases that were that were behind
um gateways but supposed to be free
making them free like that's the type of
stuff i want to do and like
if you look at debt money in politics
and defense those are three giant areas
where like there's huge things holding
us back um cost plus pricing and defense
is holding us back the palmer's working
on it debt there's just
so much debt um most of it's student or
not most of it but a lot of it's student
debt and so like there's something
interesting there of like how can you
make money but also like not be a jerk
right and also like you know take that
burden off people's plates and then
politics money and politics there's
something there because i don't think
we're just gonna magically have you know
people wake up and be like let's vote
against having this much money in
politics so like what's the world would
look like where you accelerate the money
in politics and hopefully break some of
the log jams and kind of go from there
so that's that's those are the three
things i really think about um in terms
of like post paddle life if that makes
sense
and uh sam you want to do anything on
those otherwise there's one yeah well
before we i want to get to this last one
this is interesting but i i do want to
do a quick i have a quick question which
is
you
you're 32 right 33 how old are you
uh yeah 30
33 yeah i turned 34 in a couple months
so you're 33 34. you just made a huge
sum of money have you done the math
to
when you become a billionaire
uh i'm sure you have and uh how does it
feel to have such a huge sum at such a
young age i mean
that's pretty wild right
here's the thing i learned
and some of your guests so actually
friend of the show hermosie i talked to
him a couple weeks ago
and
what i told him and he kind of was like
yeah exactly back was
it amplifies the worst in you and the
best in you you're just the same person
right so like i thought when i was gonna
get money i was gonna like oh i'm gonna
be healthier because i can like afford
you know someone to yell at me about
eating it's like no like now i can
afford to go to terrible places all the
time right and
you know i could afford that before but
like i think it's one of those things
where
i'm a big believer something i talk a
lot about and i don't know if this is
interesting but like
teddy roosevelt of all people wrote this
speech called the strenuous life
and is basically his concept and i think
it's a better speech everyone references
man in the arena i think man in the
arena is versus strenuous life he
basically said
in a modern parlance like if you've been
given something like whether it's you
know middle class life upper class life
whatever it is if you've had an exit
even though you worked for it right
whatever like your duty is to re like go
be strenuous again right your duties to
go crazy and like you know go deeper do
make big swings right and that's why i'm
talking about like i don't want to go
into quilting because it's like yeah
there's a money grab there i think it's
great but like i want to like fix
democracy i want to like have defense i
want to fix debt like i want to try and
fix those types of things um because i
think like for every person doing that
like you obviously have tons of people
that are digging ditches who have no
ability to like you know they're leading
a strenuous slice because they have to
so
yeah i'm and i know that sounds like i
don't know people judge that answer like
in multiple different ways but like yeah
i'm having fun but i'm also like all in
right like i'm trying to go and it's
part of the reason we went to paddle is
like i didn't want to like hand over the
keys because i wasn't done yet i want to
see what a company going through a
public offering like looks like like i
want to see that so that i can decide do
i like that do i want to go big next or
do i want to do more like small so
that's kind of what what i'm thinking
about if that makes sense when you were
younger
were you
kind of like highly competitive at
anything or like you know you between
ages i don't know 12 to 18
did if you look back now if you were
like a
a researcher just getting to observe you
behind the glass panel
would you have seen anything in the way
you behaved that would lead you to think
oh this guy is going to have like a
really interesting career in life or
would you have looked like an you know
an average teenager at that time
um
yeah so i had a not
i don't know how sam would look at this
i had like a midwest childhood let's say
a bad midwest childhood which is like
the things that happened to me like
would clearly be abused today but maybe
back then like they were like okay and
so
um so there was that and i think that
like that makes me an incredibly
insecure human being like i'm incredibly
insecure about like most things but what
i kind of learned and i don't know if
this was trial and error but i had some
good like mentors in life is like
instead of like taking that and go
become you know a deadbeat like channel
it right like use that anxiety like and
channel it the one thing in the answer
to your question
um
fun fact i am a national champion
debater um so i uh i did speech and
forensics um in in high school should i
make the joke john yeah
or do you like it would you consider
yourself a master 12 year old 12 year
olds i love it
yeah so i i did by the way so this is
this segment i don't know if you heard
this we did this segment on here i said
i've observed these three patterns
people who are amazing at debate go on
to do amazing in business people are
amazing gamers can go on to do amazing
um i think poker was maybe my other one
but those three are like not you
wouldn't associate that with success in
the business world but they have like
this i just keep seeing it over and over
and over again well so you know what it
is so i i did um
so i like i was doing football and like
wrestling and all that stuff i had to
have foot surgeries for whatever some
reason and
basically i was like oh i can't i can't
do wrestling that season so i went and
started doing what's called forensics
when you're in high school
and
then i was like oh you can get
scholarships so i went to the school i
went to on scholarship to to do this and
it was one of the best schools in the
country for it it's bradley university
like lovely school but like as the
northwestern kids would make fun of us
in illinois like you get a public school
education at a private school price
basically unless you're on scholarship
that type of thing and if you think
about it so what i was doing is at least
in college for 40 hours a week four
years i was synthesizing information and
structuring arguments and getting to
root cause right which are these things
that we always talk about i never wanted
to go into business i my dad still
thinks i should be a doctor i was going
to go into law law but you know more
people were graduating you know in law
school than actual legal jobs when i
graduated so long story short it was one
of those things where i was like you
know i can synthesize information really
quickly right and that's like i talk a
little faster and all this other stuff
and so i think that's that's helped me a
lot because
literally our marketing strategy in the
early days was i just write blog posts
and i can write them pretty quickly and
they're relatively deep they're not all
gems but you know it's one of those
things that that definitely helped me
and i use it i probably use it every day
you want to go to the last one sean this
is the most interesting one
you're doing you're also doing a hostile
takeover publicly traded person so i saw
this
is this guy i don't know how you say it
i've only heard like the background k
mikey m is his handle
and so there's this guy yeah yeah yeah
tell the story
who's this guy what did he do with him
what the heck are you doing
okay
so
again quickest path to learning that's i
think that's really important for like
entrepreneurs executives in general
mike merrell
like 13 years ago 2008 something like
that he became the first publicly traded
person so he sold shares in himself he's
there's an interface the the website is
a little buggy sometimes but there's an
interface he sold shares
he gets the money but then what he does
is he gets to choose to put votes up and
then the people who bought shares vote
their shares
and he doesn't do little stuff like he
does little stuff like what color
glasses should i get so a lot of the
things we probably don't want to make
decisions on ourselves which is really
interesting hack but he also what he'll
do is he goes and he'll put should i
move in with my girlfriend he puts that
up for a vote the debate is fascinating
because some of them are his friends and
his family and then there's just randos
in connecticut being like i've known
mike for like a long time through the
project i don't think this makes sense
he said this like three years ago blah
blah blah blah it's fascinating so i
knew about this
uh girlfriend what's the url again say
spell it out k mikey m k m i k e y m.com
um
so i i got a little money and i was like
i've i don't know what it's like to like
do a takeover of a company right and
this is when elon musk was like doing
his stuff with twitter
and so long story shirt i was like oh
this could be fascinating one because
there's like i don't know how people
react when this stuff happens and so he
put an auction up for um additional
shares and this is what he does every so
often when he needs some cash he'll
actually put an auction up and people
can buy
presumably if it's a dutch auction under
the share price right and i did like by
the way do you like do you get anything
as a shareholder you there's no
dividends there's no like uh nothing
like that you can sell your shares
people buy like shares so like i put my
shares up and get money like actually
get cash right dude
sean go to the website
so he he just says the things
so look let me give you an example it's
called the finger holders contract gig i
guess finger hole is the name of the
company but the short the tl dr is
should i take a short term gig contract
coordinating the development of a
community around the launch of an nft
project called finga hole finger holders
yeah and then it goes the whole
background of like why i'm interested in
this why do i want to do this what are
the contract details how much they're
going to pay me what's the proposal and
then there's 300 i think
there's like a crazy amount of comments
that says like pros working on a project
sounds fun cons nfts are divided
the uh divisive and it may alienate some
of your shareholders and there's like
incredibly thoughtful discussion on why
he totally
what
so listen to this so i sneakily i start
buying shares and i start researching
people who haven't been active because
you can see the last time they like
logged in and stuff because i want to
start contacting them he launches this
auction of about 2 000 shares and i know
that ev most votes there's only about 5
000 shares that are voting so i was like
cool if i get 2000 shares which is like
10 11 of the entire thing and then i did
a sneaky way of doing the auction which
we can get into if it's interesting but
anyways so i get the shares and then i
go speak at his shareholder meeting he
has a show how much did you pay for the
2000 shares
uh i was like 13 grand
and so his market cap is only like uh
yeah it's not it's
it's that's 130 000 where everyone gets
in yeah so right now he's got i think 16
000 shares or something that have been
sold and the share price i haven't
checked today but there's a share price
it goes up and down based on like
purchases and stuff but he's worth it
it's in the six figure range i think
ballpark i think so yeah yeah so if you
owned all the shares theoretically
that's the value but then the other
thing is the community makes it
interesting so i go speak at the
shareholder conference and i go hey and
it's on youtube and i say listen i'm
doing a hustle takeover of mike here's
why like i think the project's
undervalued you guys voted to like make
him not go on social media like that
doesn't make sense like in order to get
more people he has to like do this blah
blah i think and then all the questions
are like
well what about like is this good for
mike because there's a lot of his
friends like his actual in-person
friends
and i was like listen i think what's
good for what's good for the share price
is good for mike and vice versa and i
talk
about it it's like a half hour interview
i did and and then everyone and then
there's all these people especially the
people who don't know him who are like i
think patrick i think the takeover is
good for the project i think it's this
you only need to go through lulls 500 to
a thousand more shares roughly to
control the vote you thought
uh no no i already i already had i got
1930 out of the auction right right but
you said each vote has about five
thousand and you just need that yeah you
just need 51. it's never it's never
one-sided it's never one-sided so like
if it's
can swing 2500 vote
and and what's funny is i'm texting him
and i'm like hey man just so you know
here are my intentions like it's like a
little it's a little takeover right that
that's cool that's like some insider
trading though no
uh no i didn't i don't do anything just
like when he left the shares elon goes
and talks to perrag and he's like hey
look i'm doing this and here's what i
want to do with twitter and also there's
kind of nothing you could do about it
but i'm going to inform you because that
just seems like you know the standard
the writing process here yeah
what does uh what is what obligation
does this guy have to follow what you
say like we know what if he just says ah
off i'm done with this project
in i mean he could shut the project down
i don't know like so first before i
started doing this i started tweeting to
him about
what happens if there was a hostile
takeover elon musk seems interesting
right because i wanted to see like is
this like it's is this gonna be a good
investment probably not but like i'm
learning i can't tell you how much i'm
learning right because all of a sudden
it's like oh interesting shareholder
mate they responded to this and these
aren't like the investors that i want to
be working with in the rest of my life
but it's really fascinating um he has
never for to my knowledge in 13 years
gone against what a vote has said but he
could it's all in good faith he could i
mean there's no yeah there's no like oh
my god i can sue him or anything also he
he gets to choose what he puts up for
vote so if he's like yeah you know i
just want to move on to my girlfriend i
don't have to put it up for a vote but
there has been some talk of you get to
burn some of your shares in order to put
a vote up for a vote
which is fascinating it's he's been
covered by wired atlantic all kinds of
stuff it's it was in a lull and i'm
injecting some excitement into it again
and yeah i'm looking at the price chart
so it looks like it's it started 2008
it opened at a dollar 99 cents it looks
like
and it basically was like between one
and three dollars then it kind of peaked
in 2013 maybe he got some press or
something like that it was 13 yeah 1350
something like that and then for the
last six years it's basically been flat
at roughly four or five bucks
for a takeover and and now it's 685
right now and so um it was about five
when i started the takeover this is far
more interesting to be as small as as it
is right i mean it's
cool to be as unknown of a project it
feels it feels unknown to be as unknown
of a project as it is it's been around
this 2008
it's pretty
under covered right
well so in the beginning he got a lot he
was like on the today show he was on all
kinds of stuff
and then he did because what was
interesting is he's had some epics with
it like a project was i think it was
called the girlfriend project and it was
literally about his relationship his his
girlfriend buys shares his ex-girlfriend
is still a shareholder i'm pretty sure
his current i don't know if it's his
wife or not is like a shirt like and
that was the end of the shareholders
meeting was his ex-girlfriend his
current girlfriend or wife having a
conversation it was the most interesting
like half hour i've ever seen in my life
because they were just and they're
friendly i think there might be friends
but just them talking about mike and
it's kind of beautiful because you have
all these people who like either just
from a money perspective or just a
fascination perspective in my case or
from a love perspective like supporting
this guy and like trying to make the
right decisions for him so i think it's
brilliant like as soon as i announced
this on twitter we got some inbound from
like some like i don't think they're
documentarians or something like that
like i don't know if it'll come with
anything but it's like it's a
fascinating story that i think deserves
more more more give so i'm glad you
asked about it because you guys have a
pretty medium audience so it's great
there's there's even like a what happens
when i die like unlike a company i will
die so what happens to my shares after i
die there's like
this is pretty crazy i mean it kind of
makes no sense in that like yeah you
know there's
yeah it's completely nonsensical yeah
but bro you bought a 150 000
image of a monkey so like this is
you know like did you buy a name
punk
you got a oh you're a punk guy this is
from ape fest so this is my nice fun
little yeah it was a 50 it was a coin
flip to uh use the milk portfolio either
we buy up an ape or a punk and they were
the same price on that day
and we knew that the the purchase was
gonna have to happen the board was about
to buy the punks and so it was like what
do we which asset should we buy knowing
this news is about to break or it has
just broken or something
and we flipped punk and then apes went
through the roof
and punched something down everything's
down now too
it's interesting very interesting dude
check this out so if you go to uh mike's
blog so there's news.kmikeem.com
where he like it's ran like a
shareholder company i mean like like the
investor relations page of a publicly
traded company and he has the list of
all of his principles and on health it
says like as of october 23 2019 i'm in
favor of experimenting with psychedelics
and you click psychedelics and there's a
like notes from a board meeting about
like who voted and why they voted and
what is the reason and what the
reasoning is and how they are or are not
going to start doing psychedelics then
in 2016 i will not take uh a psyllium
pills i don't know what that is um and
it's like talks about why he wanted to
take them and everyone's voting and he
has like a update on that and then like
entertainment um
shareholders will have direct control
over my television television watching i
will and then 2019 i will watch
spiderman
um
i will not subscribe to spotify
uh
yeah some of these are like stupid like
the glasses one it says that 34 users
voted with 1800 shares
so 34 people participated in that vote
for the glasses i guess that was not a
very uh
not a very big one let's see this and if
i didn't
put i haven't i'm pretty 44 people like
who he's voting for like president up
like he's done stuff like that as well
which gets really fascinating yeah but
that's just as meaningless as the
classes interesting
uh i believe he's in oregon so i'm not
sure i mean he's in a state that is
going to vote one way or the other
anyways
wow yeah 2020 i will endorse bernie
sanders for president
okay uh amazing listen man this was this
was fun uh i'm glad you came on and uh
yeah good times thank you brought some
good stuff sam what do you think
dude can you send me send me the uh the
research thing that was the most
fascinating thing that was really
interesting
and i'll send you some redacted i'll
send you the structure and you can don't
redact it no no one will i won't share
it with any of these losers it'll just
be for me
don't get back let me think about it i
met again i have a boss i'm on a board i
gotta be careful now so yeah well are
you guys i'll send you something and
paddle isn't public now but it will be
right
uh i mean we're
we're not going next year in a number of
years probably before anything like that
right but i'm great
you know there's no laws
[Laughter]
i'll hook you up i'll hook you up with
something don't worry don't worry this
was awesome i i typically hate having
not hate i say no to everyone
shawn brought you in yeah we kind of
hate having guests
but
then we have many ways and we're not
we're not fully sure why we do it but we
do it in the moment it seems like a good
idea halfway through the episode it's
like yeah i kind of wish i was just
bullshitting with sam uh instead of
doing this conversation but i'm always
happy when we do it because i don't have
to prepare
but um
one out of every four is awesome and
i'll just hope that everybody thinks
they're that one out of four you
actually were that one out of four so
good for you what makes a good guest
versus not a good guess just for the
audience to hear if they come in they
listen to the pod if they already know
the vibe if they know the the what's
cool that that tends to work really well
i think what do you think sam
i agree and most people ha most people
aren't like sean and i and that they
don't do this for a living and so they
need to come prepared with the things
and even us we come some the re we do
research sometimes we do sometimes we
don't but there's at least bullet points
so it's like all right next and you did
a good job of saying next a lot of
people um if you i don't know if you
paid attention but sean very purposely
in the beginning he's like i don't
really care about the company in your
background let's just move on to the
other stuff and uh we actually we we
tend to do that a lot and so that was
cool um and so that's also the least
interesting except for michael saylor
that episode was like
that episode was money because he was
just so weird like it was just like
what's gonna happen guys like what's
gonna happen the next minute that was
that was an interesting one did you hear
when he out alfied me i was like yeah i
like fast cars he goes hey i don't like
fast cars
but i have a really fast jet
that's well no the quote the quote i
tell everyone from that episode is
yeah i don't really like things that you
can't in normal use go at their max
speed like and that's what he was
referring to with cars like it was like
boats and jets i'm allowed to to go at
max speed you know cars not really so
i just i thought who even has that
thought about like am i utilizing this
machine to its fullest velocity
into bitcoin that's that's who has that
thought which is great that those people
exist dude sean i did you see on my
instagram or twitter or something i did
i uh this weekend i was in the hamptons
uh that's not a humble brag it was my
in-laws house so i had nothing to do
with it but and that's a midwest thing
he just did a midwest thing just so you
know they're very very blessed
oh i have a yeah i have an equinox
member but like they're gonna do my
laundry so it's like worth it was on
sale
it was my in-laws house and i went out
there and i drove we went to the beach
for a bonfire in the fourth and we drove
by this area that was just pat it was
like a it's like a small one-lane road
and it was packed full of cars but they
were fancy cars and in front of me was a
bugatti and it was a special bugatti and
i looked it up there's like a 5 million
bugatti and i was like what the is
going on here and so i get to the
parking lot to park my car and it was
full of black limousines but not
limousines like the escalades full of
them and then in the corner one of the
limos had their trunk open and literally
i'm not exaggerating i have a video of
it a hundred limousine drivers were just
hanging out drinking coke eating chips
and i was like what the is going on
here and they go it's michael rubin's
party uh michael rubin has a famous
white party and i made a joke i was like
he only lets whites in which
they didn't like the drivers no yeah
yeah i was like you know like oh white's
holy really that's weird maybe i should
go um
i don't know it was a bad joke
and anyway i go
reuben and they go yeah it's reuben he
um
he's having this party he's famous he
goes i drove this one guy was like yeah
we drove drake and it's like i was like
yeah jay-z's there and i was like wait
really and i looked it up on instagram
and it was this crazy party and i was
like uh well tell me everything he goes
you know i drove this guy and he's broke
one guy goes uh i drove tyreese you
remember tyreese from fast and furious
yeah yeah yeah he's like i drove that
guy and and the driver goes i'm richer
than he is that guy's broker than a joke
i got more money than that guy and i was
like wait what really and he like
auditioned he he kept telling me all
this said he goes the guys who are
really rich they typically drive
themselves because they got that bugatti
and they want to show it off um but
it was really fascinating i was just
hanging with these we hung with them for
like half an hour just asking them all
rumors and gossip and they knew it all
dude that's amazing i after you you sent
that you sent me that video and then i
went on instagram and i saw like six nba
players were posting stories from the
party so i was like james harden's at
the party
and then whoever you know like these
other guys were you know joel embiids at
the party and it's the all-white party
wherever it is uh everybody's uh like it
was just rappers and athletes it seemed
like which is which is great exactly
it was it was so cool and like
he's got like this private beach area
and then we were like 100 yards down the
beach and right next to the parking lot
and it was just packed and we there's
bugattis there's all these crazy cars it
was pretty it was i just imagined you in
the in the party with like you know that
meme where it's the guy at the party
yelling into the girl's ear and you're
just like it's a newsletter
we
my first million i said million
yeah no no with an m do you use spotify
we're up there you got video access on
there
no we mostly talk about 12 year old
stuff but it's pretty cool
sean no he's not here he doesn't leave
his house
[Laughter]
sometimes he has long hair sometimes he
has short hair i don't know no i'm not
my in-laws live here
no my dad in law is jacked more than i
am it's kind of uncomfortable sometimes
that's up
that bit will not get old for a while
that's awesome i guess we should we
gotta end there right yeah
thanks for coming dude
[Music]
you